hey what's up welcome to our viewers I'm
here in the CBS this morning Toyota
greenroom with CBS news medical
contributor dr. David agus welcome Len
he is here to discuss growing concerns
about how public genealogy databases
could compromise our privacy
investigators used online DNA databases
in April to zero in on the suspected
Golden State Killer they were able to
identify his potential relatives based
on DNA collected at one of the crime
scenes good to see you but it's kind of
cool when you say serial killers is our
topic a serial killers is our topic and
more importantly it's how they're using
DNA which is unique to every single
living person on the planet to track
down cold cases yeah what's so I mean
just give me a little bit so you
wouldn't when you first heard they were
able to track down this killer using DNA
what do you think I knew was gonna
happen I mean this is inevitable when
you have a child right it kicks chunks
of your DNA and chunks of your wife DNA
and they go together and that's what the
child is so we inherit big chunks not
individual letters and you could trace
back those chunks and see your genealogy
so we've all had friends who have done
it and discovered that they were Italian
instead of I right but what's amazing is
you put it into these databases and then
a day later you get an email from all
the people who they think may be related
to you and you see your 20% like this
person 4% like this person and so you
can imagine taking DNA of a killer and
put it into that same database and once
you identify who they're related to you
call that person up and say which of
your relatives are out there and you can
identify the killer so when you go into
that database with your DNA you're
potentially implicating a family member
right but and we should point out that
the reason they were able to do this is
the police were able to look at public
databases so when you go on to for
example sites like ancestry.com or
23andme
everybody buys one of those little kits
you swab the inside of your mouth you
send the DNA to the ancestry website and
the hope there is that you'll find some
family members or you'll know a little
bit more about who you are where you
came from and now the police can access
those databases right so those are
private databases so presumably they
need a court order to go in and take
those databases the interesting
workaround saying
a policewoman and you have DNA from a
crime you could just send it into Santa
Street a common put a fake name on it
and see who they're related to so
there's a quick workaround here to get
information out of those databases you
know I went to ancestry.com for example
online and this is this is the Terms and
consents that you do for it it's 16
pages so first of all if you read this
you'd be sound asleep but I want to read
to you you know one part of the content
and I'm not implicating anyone right
buddy but this is just the field in
general it says you grant us a sub
licensable worldwide royalty-free
license to host store copy published
distribute provide access to create
derivative works us and otherwise use
your content so they it gives them wide
latitude this is your age this is your
DNA this is who you are this is the
stuff of life but it's not just you it's
all your family so when you go through a
test whether it be looking for the
breast cancer gene or going to
ancestry.com it says something about all
of your family yeah so if you're gonna
have this breast test you want to talk
to your parents your sister because it
applies something about them if you do
this you got to think about your family
as a whole and so it's a whole new way
of approaching things that we haven't
really consider here so what is genetic
discrimination haha so President Bush
you put together a bill called Gena the
genetic non-discrimination Act it had
gone before Congress literally for
dozens of times and always got turned
down because someone would attach a
bridge to it or Road took it was such a
number out of pork Oh what it means is
is that if I know it's employer listen
you know you have a risk factor for
heart disease heart disease a heart
attack cost the company seventy thousand
dollars I'm gonna hire you know her
because she doesn't have that risk so
it's actually making a decision with
your genetics in mind right these are
not deterministic these gene traits but
they tell you they're probabilistic
nature what's the probability of you
getting cancer and heart disease if
they're high as a company I say listen
it's gonna cost me money on self in
short or you're gonna miss work time
that may take someone that doesn't have
a risk for disease is better for my
company but are you saying then that
companies can actually also access some
of these databases to learn this
information or this is okay let's put
together this like right yet to be a
case in the United
ever of someone being discriminated
based on genetics but people have said I
know you're a smoker yeah I don't know
because that's not genetics right yeah I
mean there was an amazing case last year
where the AARP sued the EEOC I love all
these letters and they said that you
know companies should not have their own
wellness program
you know CBS had a wellness program and
it knew you had diabetes but it said
Nora didn't when there's a story in
London maybe David Rhodes the head of
the news says I'm gonna send an or
because I don't want him to be stressed
because she has a disorder and so they
said listen if you're a corporate
wellness programs and you show up with
the diabetes one people may know you
have diabetes and that's not right and
they won and so right now corporate
wellness programs shouldn't be part of
the company they should be separate so
now do you expect going forward that
many police departments will be looking
at some of their cold cases that they've
had sitting for years and years and
years and maybe get a court order or
warrant and start looking into some of
these databases to figure out who they
may come up with they are I mean I think
they are doing that and again there's a
workaround here you know someone there's
a rape you could take some of that sperm
put it in that same tube that you spit
into send it to them and then they'll
run the search and it'll say who you're
similar to and then the police officers
can just call up those people and say
tell me about your relatives and they
can identify the person so certainly if
you're a victim this is the greatest
thing in the world we can start to
identify people at the same time privacy
you know advocates are worried about
this how so I read a fascinating book
years ago about how fingerprinting was
for many many years in the nineteenth
century not considered to be a real form
of evidence until finally it was right
and so to me it would seem that we know
that fingerprints are unique to each
individual DNA it's sort of it sort of
feels that if you get arrested if you
are caught because of your DNA match how
do you what's the defense against that
there is no des there is no it's three
billion letters with an infinite number
of combinations so if you can look at
the DNA it's a match it is you there's
no way around it you could say someone
put your DNA sure someone took your hair
out of your car put it on how you got
there is one thing but it we should be
writing this down I have a good drama
we could maybe we can write a really
interesting crime novel about this and
so and you and you mentioned the privacy
concerns that some people have what
should people know just regular you know
folks on the street who decide that they
want to share their DNA with some of
these sites what should they think about
before the average person you know
there's medical doctor I ain't gonna
read the right you know I literally I
started doing it my eyes glaze over and
I'm kind of leaning backwards here and
so what you need to realize is that DNA
is your identity it's very important
when you put information in these
companies it's the potential to get out
there it's the be able to use not just
against you but your family members and
maybe that's ok with you but you have
the right to make that decision for
yourself you know we treat DNA as
society different than everything else
right you go and you try to get a
mortgage in your home you give them
every bit of financial information
you've ever had I mean they know
everything you do and you don't think
twice about it but if I tell you your
DNA may be shared it someone gonna have
access to you get up in arms and so we
do view DNA differently and we have to
realize that and so to me it's the
transparency I really you know I hate so
every company does this these 16 pages
and to me in a sense it pisses me off
people don't understand it or read it
I want legible clear transparency to say
what's going to happen with this DNA and
what you could expect to what could
happen and then you can make the right
decision for yourself maybe you don't
care maybe you want to democratize your
information and to you it's not not it
but you may have a cousin George you're
worried about and I don't want to get
George in trouble well I think that
that's the struggle that everybody is
facing right now some people will say
well you know I don't really mind about
my DNA or even sharing some of my for
example movements on social media I
don't care I haven't done anything wrong
it's not a big deal but what is sort of
more opaque is that some of these
companies don't really care about you
yes you're open and so they know what
you're gonna do where you're gonna shop
they want to know about your son and
your daughter and your grandparents and
your loved ones and what that you they
want to be able to track them and that's
a little bit more to spit inserting
because you're giving up to yourself but
you're not giving up extended family
members no at least not when you're when
you're signing some of these consent
forms but yeah you know it goes very
very deep you know if you had the test
to see if you had the gene for breast
cancer or not it's a terminus t'k for
eighty five eighty eight percent chance
of your lifetime you get any breast
cancer and if you turned out positive
that implies something about your sister
she is a fifty percent
chance of having it about your mother
about your father about your children
about your cousins and so do you consent
them before you have the test and so we
as a society have to start to have these
discussions because I think they're
critical yeah they really are
dr. David agus it's really interesting
to talk to you about this interesting or
scary you make it's a little bit of both
it's a little bit of both because on one
hand like I said it's it's interesting
for years and years I because of the
fact that my parents were divorced when
I was very young my grand my paternal
grandmother died in childbirth so I
never knew her giving birth to my dad my
mother's father my maternal grandparents
father grew maternal grandfather she
never knew
so my fam might might the knowledge of
my family is really only extended to my
mother and my dad I don't know anything
about who or where I came from other
than family legends and family myths and
so for years I've thought I want to put
my DNA into one of these databases and
at least get some connections in fact I
have a cousin who's visiting here
tomorrow who's part of the Scandinavian
wing of my family and they're not and
she's not that distantly related she is
the granddaughter of my great-uncle so
it's a it's a second cousin basically
and yet I don't know a lot about her and
so it's just interesting to me that you
can use this database to figure out who
you are on the other hand I'm certainly
worried about what it could mean for my
privacy I haven't done anything wrong I
haven't like you know they're not gonna
find me well I guess the black dahlia
murder rape murder but but you know it
affects my family very definitely my
father-in-law is Maury Povich so
Lauren's made a career on saying you are
they the father are they knocked upon
it's a big issue you know yeah you know
listen what happened five generations
ago you didn't know that part of your
family is you know Native American bride
of your families right you can find a
lot of laughs in this you've got about
behavior of people you know generations
pass there's a lot of information
sitting in your own DNA does it deserve
to be liberated and are you this is sort
of a question about just these sites in
general are you as a doctor can you say
that with some certainty that they kind
of get it right when they come back with
the results that's a very important
question I mean
you know in all just goes right help
develop some of these things and I will
tell you they're not perfect okay no
question about it so your genealogy is
not perfect and anybody could say
exactly where you're from they could say
you have traits consistent with somebody
who spent time in Ireland but there's a
lot of mixing and matching that happen
over the generations that Irish person
may have gone to China
and Wright had relations with a woman
and so there may be some Chinese there's
a lot of mixing and matching it's not
pure and it's not perfect science but
you are perfect dr. David agus and we're
happy to have you we all do we all do
alright thank you very much for being
with us in the Toyota greenroom here at
CBS this morning we appreciate it
we are signing off we'll see you the
next time thanks so much bye-bye